so we're out for a walk in London it's
kind of a cool day but it's lovely to
walk it's not raining and you know I
found I talked about today is how you
know language learning this is this Sufi
which is a Muslim philosophy of some
kind I don't know much about it but
there was a saying that said you can
only learn things that you already know
and I have this thing about learning you
can only learn things that you've
exposed been exposed to before so I said
before don't study don't study languages
expose yourself to them and gradually
you will learn them and and one of the
things that happened to me was that you
know in preparation for going to Morocco
I studied Miley Arabic hard then we had
five days in Morocco where I used some
of my Arabic and then since I left our
but I left Morocco come and have come to
London I've been working on Farsi for
like ten days the other day I went to
the store short walk and I turned on my
Arabic on my mp3 player and lo and
behold the Arabic was much clearer than
before I seem to hear the sort of
different forms of the verbs I heard the
words more clearly and it made me
realize that one of the things that I
read I can leave a link in the
description box about how we learned
best from things that we are already
familiar with that we are relearning so
I go back to the Arabic which I've left
and I'm learning it better I think we
should learn languages backwards we
shouldn't start by trying to learn
grammar we should first as I've said
before expose ourselves to the language
so that some of that socks in there so
it's now already something that we've
been exposed to which we've kind of
learned without studying it and I never
try to learn anything I just try to
expose myself to it and then when I go
back to it again it's kind of I learn it
better and I have the same feeling when
I'm going through new texts now in Farsi
and there's lots there that I'm not
going to remember new words that I'm not
going to remember it doesn't matter
I will maybe study something else and
some of those words will show up or I'll
go back to the old lesson again and
slowly these things will start to stick
so I think we do a great disservice to
language learners when we expect them to
remember what was taught or when
language learners expect of themselves
that they're gonna remember what they're
trying to learn
you won't you're just exposing yourself
to something and you'll go back and
revisit it again and forget it and go
back again and eventually these things
start to stick and so I think if we have
this attitude of exploring without
trying to retain anything actually in
the long run we will try to retain a lot
so maybe we should try to learn
languages backwards and that's all I
have to say and now we're going to
continue our walk now
[Music]